okay Shh so at last we're finishing
working at multimedia production
software and that's going to finish this
out for the year okay now let's just
review a little bit because there's some
this lesson seems to be taking forever
we look before at four different kinds
of software for producing multimedia do
you remember what they were I see if we
try and review we looked at four there
was a certain order to them if you
remember that we'll get to that in a
second what was the first kind that we
looked at the first input good and so
these were sort of the kinds of piece of
software that are very broad in their
design they're able to do lots and lots
of things kinda like a Swiss Army knife
for multimedia software and do a lot of
things but they can't necessarily do any
of them particularly well but they can
do it to sort of ok standard right what
was next after that authoring packages
right so we're looking at hence the name
things that people who are you know
actual authors of specific kinds of data
like say you know recording artists or
you know desktop publishing magazines
that kind of thing people who want to a
bit more of a professional quality and
things right they'll use something which
is more specific but more expensive and
slower bit more difficult to use ok what
was after that what was the next step up
everyone
yeah thank you so the whole idea here is
we want to have even more control and
even more flexibility to sort of muck
around with the code that makes up the
multimedia we're looking at but the
whole idea of this software is you don't
have to yourself directly looking around
at the code it'll sort of hold your hand
and guide you and semi-automatically do
it for you okay and then of course the
last one the most complex where as a
programming language and I actually
going to show you a really amazing
example of one that i found today
actually this morning which languages um
which and there was people to have the
up those control over something they're
not having to deal with what someone
else allows you to do all the templates
that someone else's me you're just doing
it for yourself from sketch but for that
reason as quite complex after you need
people who aren't specifically skilled
and doing this kind of thing and we said
as you progress down right as you go
from one through 24 you're increasing in
four different ways remember what the
ways were I tried to make them all start
with the letter C but it didn't quite
work we said we're increasing in cost
everything gets more expensive as you go
further down we were including
increasing in control as you go from up
here you know you sort of limited you're
like oh you're going to use these fonts
or the fonts that you've got you can
only adjust in certain ways you get more
and more control as you get further down
you like I can make my own fun and make
a whole new thing right cost control
complexity as you look at these kinds of
things it's a lot trickier in the
machines and multimedia that you build
will be far more composed of many pieces
and there'll be systems whereas these
are quite simple and lastly we said I
remind you of this work it's an
important one we increase in terms of
abstraction so up the top here these
kinds of tools are what we call WYSIWYG
right what you see is what you get it
what you're working on literally looks
like what your end up going to end up
producing whereas when you look at this
I'll just show you an example down
oh where is it that's interesting there
we go I found it okay so we're looking
at here the pro image that was used to
build just this web page you're looking
at which is multimedia by the way
there's multi-media this right um you
look at this you think whoa it's really
abstract this looks nothing like it
doesn't even look like English actually
some of it like what is this business
okay so very abstract very difficult to
understand right and it gets
increasingly abstract as you go further
down okay now I we said that these were
four kinds of multimedia production
software okay but now coming back to
let's get rid of that on this third task
here that's let's think this through
explain how advances you here are the
key words miniaturization and
communications technology have those
advances open new categories of
multimedia production and any software
okay now is a bit of a mouthful but
let's just take it one piece of time
miniaturization what does that refer to
maybe something small up right baking
something swatter so when it comes to
you need mini two-tier weight on earth I
gotta wrong the A's there this is such a
hundred making things smaller what
examples do you think of um in terms of
multimedia then has gotten smaller over
the last few years well you record
yeah good okay with any kind of
technology right to do with creating
images or sound or audio sorry or video
it's all getting smaller so you know the
collective hardware for this but also
the processing power to be able to
produce an edit and process multimedia
that's all we're interested in today
right I is also getting smaller right so
all right where do you in Toronto video
thanks ok lieutenant um all of these
things are getting smaller ok and I'm
more accessible and cheaper all that
kind of thing so what does that mean
well it opens up a whole new category of
software come back to this idea here
right all these kinds of software what
what kinds of devices do they run on
word premier Photoshop all these kinds
of examples here Dreamweaver what do
they run on they're generally run on
desktop computers right all laptops if
you like same kind of category right so
they're right off full-fledged machines
but now you've got amazingly powerful
processors that exist in function within
really small four factors right so I
guess we would see you things like
tablets smartphones so we were talking
about desktop software yesterday right
but all of these I guess we would want
them under the category of mobile
software mobile software
okay does this make sense to get a whole
new category off things like say you
know I movie right right on your phone
you can put together and edit a video
you can make it quite quite nice looking
actually you can make all kinds of
justice to it right on your phone okay
or your I point actually so mobile
software right can you see what we're
getting out here advances in
miniaturization have made mobile
software actually a legitimate
multimedia production platform okay all
right now what about this communications
technologies the internet is getting
faster right and the internet is getting
everywhere so how does that has that
affected multimedia production editing
so I think one person yesterday
mentioned that google sites google sites
was a one kind of multimedia production
software right you can edit make
websites but the funny thing I google
science right is where is Google Sites
installed where's where's the actual
program the software where is it
installed it's not at its mind your
computer and it's not on it's not even
on you know a phone or a tablet you can
get to it on any device because it's
installed on Google's servers right in
the same way if you have a youtube
account right you'll know that when you
upload your video there you it's not
just stuck right over you or any other
kind of service right it's not just
there in a sort of immutable
unchangeable form you can edit it you
can adjust lighting you can even add um
what's one of some sort of looking for
stability control like if your video if
your hands are really like shaky right
you upload your video and YouTube will
say hey we notice your video is really
shaky do you want us to stabilize it now
what's all this this is multimedia
editing that's happening where is it
happening it's not on your desktop it's
not on the mobile mobile device itself
we would call all of this
cloud softly it's all actually happy on
someone else's computer of someone
else's device on another server that
we're reaching through the internet okay
and all this is practical because they
are internet bandwidth his advance and
is so powerful and broad now that you
can actually practically do stuff edit
things over the internet it's quite
amazing wasn't practical at all before
so that's what i mean by it's opened up
new categories right the categories we
looked at before they're just one way of
thinking about things as you get your
computer at you increase in cost control
complexity and abstraction right but
there's this whole new sort of world
that's opening up it doesn't have quite
the same functionality right you can't
do everything on say true besides you
can do and dreamweaver you can't do
everything on imovie that you you know I
phone you can do an iMovie further back
for example but you can do a lot of
things and in fact some things you can
do even better like say sharing right
that works really well on your phone
just you can just send it straight off
so that's what we mean by the different
ways you could think about multimedia
production software so think of these
two different ways of categorizing okay
one is all for the desktop kind of means
and the other one is what what platform
are you on your on your desktop or I
learn a mobile device or in accessing
services and software through the cloud
okay